[Musica]
buonasera a tutti io mi chiamo gianni
gianni massa anche se tutti mi chiamano
dandy perché dandy il mio soprannome da
quando poco più di un anno che non
riuscivo a dire bene il mio il mio nome
sono sono il papà di due fantastiche
ragazze giulia e sofia il marito di ale
e sono un ingegnere è un architetto e da
alcuni anni sto facendo anche
un'esperienza bella difficile complessa
che quella della della rappresentanza
perché sono il vice presidente del
consiglio nazionale ingegneri
dell'ingegneria italiana passione ho
scritto qui alcune definizioni secondo
me di di passione passione e sofferenza
fisica e spirituale il colore della
passione secondo me è il rosso e la
passione è fuoco il verbo e bruciare ma
anche seguire coltivare tutti noi
seguiamo le nostre passioni chi più chi
meno
dobbiamo insegnare ai nostri figli ai
bambini di seguire e coltivare le
proprie passioni passione emozione
emozioni sono pulsioni pulsioni
razionalmente incomprensibili
alcune volte spesso anzi incontrollabili
e innamoramento e amore e chimica e
fisica insieme
che che insieme riescono a trasformare
il fare nell'essere il fare qualcosa
nell'essere qualcosa passione
l'abbiamo visto anche prima può essere
cambiamento passione e forza passione
energia ma è anche vulnerabilità
passione può essere immortalità
sicuramente felicità
ce ne sono tante di definizioni però per
me sono tutte queste insieme tutte
quelle che ho visto scritte anche in
questa sala perché sono gli incroci gli
incroci di tutti questa è di tutte
queste forze i miliardi di miliardi di
incroci incroci d'idee di persone e di
luoghi di sogni di elementi naturali che
influenzano il carattere dei popoli e
tutti questi miliardi di miliardi di
incroci sono poi quelli che che generano
il il movimento un movimento lentissimo
impercettibile che a volte però diventa
improvviso repentino che può diventare
violento che poi è il movimento che è la
storia di noi umani che attraversiamo
questo universo in questo in questo
tempo e allora per questo proverò a dire
la mia idea di passione con alcuni
incroci ne potevo scegliere tanti legati
all'architettura all'ingegneria ne ho
scelto alcuni stasera
aprile 1970 cagliari stadio amsicora
precisamente sono le 16 e 45 del 12
aprile in quel momento in quel preciso
istante il cagliari allenato da manlio
scopigno vince lo scudetto è un sogno un
sogno collettivo che diventa realtà
ma quella vittoria quello scudetto non è
la vittoria della squadra non è la
vittoria di una città
cagliari no quella vittoria la vittoria
di una regione intera è il simbolo di un
riscatto sociale di un popolo e della
sua e della sua terra una terra
selvaggia e ospitale allo stesso tempo
una terra antica e profonda la sardegna
forse si sente da dove vengo
una terra in quegli anni erano gli anni
sessanta che se non ce li nato ci arriva
vi per punizione non è che c'è che ci
andavi a fare il turista
ebbene quel momento quel preciso momento
alle 16 e 45 del 12 aprile del 1970 c'è
un simbolo che racchiude quel momento
quel movimento della storia anche della
storia dell'uomo
quel simbolo e lui e gigi riva noi
gigi riva lo pronunciamo rigorosamente
tutto attaccato e raddoppiando qualunque
consonante si sente lui un ragazzo non è
sardo è nato in un paese di provincia in
un paese della provincia di varese passa
e trascorre una giovinezza con con tanta
sofferenza per dei genitori e una
sorella giovanissimo e poi coltiva segue
la sua passione il gioco del calcio del
pallone no e poi a un certo punto un
incrocio uno di quei miliardi di
miliardi di incroci frutto di miliardi
di miliardi di altri
croci call casuali alcuni volontari
alcuni fortissimamente voluti la
sardegna non è una sua scelta e un
incrocio arriva in sardegna coltiva la
sua passione con sacrificio con grande
sacrificio fa diventare quello la sua
passione diventa il suo lavoro e poi e
poi il resto lo fanno altri incroci lo
fanno le n elevato en variabili
l'intelligenza la dedizione
l'allenamento
la forza della squadra forze politiche
economiche estetiche casuali fanno il
resto e trasferiscono quel sogno
collettivo dal mondo della possibilità a
quello della realtà un incrocio una
passione perché è una passione perché io
non ho visto giocare gigi riva
non ero presente fisicamente alle 16 e
45 in quell'incrocio ma come tantissimi
bambini
ho sognato di diventare calciatore ho
anche giocato a calcio non significa
seguire la propria passione non
significa per forza diventare famosi
significa essere felici e questo è stato
adesso aprile 2014
siamo a ginevra al cern il tempio
mondiale della ricerca scientifica il
luogo dove si sovrappongono cervelli
talenti il luogo delle formule degli
algoritmi dei teoremi degli integrali il
luogo della contaminazione per
eccellenza il luogo dove i fisici
lavorano insieme agli ingegneri che già
questo è abbastanza strano e insieme
ingegneri e fisici lavorano con
matematici incredibile il luogo dove la
passione di tanti ricercatori ha avuto
il riconoscimento del nobel
pensiamo a guglielmo marconi a enrico
fermi a einstein a richard faymann solo
per citarne qualcuno
il luogo dove si ricerca l'origine
dell'universo il luogo dove si cerca la
particella di dio
ebbene dopo un controllo alla sicurezza
degno dei film più fighi di spionaggio
americano mi sembrava di andare al
pentagono arrivo è mischiato nella sala
del consiglio di fronte a me c'era una
platea importante c'era il direttore
generale del cern e c'erano scienziati e
rappresentanti di tutte le nazioni degli
stati degli stati membri e perché ero lì
ero lì perché proprio lì in quel luogo
hanno notato un progetto il progetto
scintille che non è un mio progetto in
progetto fatto da una squadra fantastica
e vogliono sentire che cosa è questo
progetto per capire se prenderlo è fare
un percorso insieme
ovviamente un po come adesso l'emozione
mi prende totalmente la mia salivazione
il 100 per cento della mia federazione
non c'è più perché quella non è
solamente la mia di emozione e
l'emozione degli oltre 1200 ragazzi e
ragazze che hanno costruito e
partecipato al progetto scintille e
l'emozione della squadra fantastica dei
ragazzi della redazione che ogni giorno
va nei territori a scoprire le scintille
a cercare di dargli l'opportunità di non
rimanere scintille per spegnersi ma di
poter diventare un fuoco e l'emozione di
chi anche insieme a me ha ideato
coordinato e gestisce questo progetto
con tutta l'energia e tutta la forza che
io lì non avevo ma che tutti questi che
ho appena detto mi hanno dato inizio a
parlare e adesso interpretò me stesso le
tecnologia è pensiero tecnologia e
creatività e se creatività e se anche
passione incide inevitabilmente nelle
culture e vedete c'è un problema perché
soprattutto noi ingegneri siamo stati
abituati alla scomposizione e alla
dizione
in che senso di fronte a un problema che
ci appare complesso lo scomponiamo in
problemi semplici e poi ne sommiamo le
soluzioni scomposizione e addizione ma
la complessità non è comprimibile non è
the costruibili equa un altro incrocio
uno di quei miliardi di miliardi di
incroci frutto di miliardi di miliardi
di altri incroci casuali o meno quello
tra un allievo e il maestro silvano
tagliagambe mi ha insegnato la
differenza tra semplicità e complessità
e mi ha fatto e ci ha fatto lavorare su
come questo confine tra semplice e
complesso potesse essere portato nel
mondo dell'ingegneria nel mondo
dell'architettura e nel mondo che da
alcuni anni rappresenta quello di tutta
all'ingegneria italiana semplice
significa semel black ter cioè piegare
una volta sola se prendo questo foglio
che mi sono ricordato di mettermi in
tasca e lo piega una volta sola e ne
faccio una sola piega
se facessi scorrere una pallina su
questa piega posso con ragionevole
certezza prevederne e studiarne il
decorso la traiettoria complesso
significa molte piega se io a pallottola
si questo foglio e ne facessi un origami
non so più con la mia sola competenza
descrivere e prevedere la traiettoria di
quella stessa pallina e caro direttore
generale del cern cari scienziati questo
riga mi è scintille e scintille dico a
tutti voi è un concorso a cui
partecipano e hanno partecipato
tantissime persone linguaggi differenti
è una redazione un blog che scopre le
scintille è una narrazione che facciamo
nelle città nei territori e in quel
momento
dopo tanti incroci casuali
il cern decide di sposare il progetto
entrare dentro scintille
ho portato il momento della firma quello
e lui è sergio bertolucci direttore
della ricerca del cern cerali anche
fabiola gianotti forse la riconoscete
fabiola poi è diventata il direttore
generale del dl certo questo è un
incrocio che riguarda la mia persona
questo che ti ho appena raccontato un
altro incrocio sempre aprile 1979
siamo a cagliari al palazzo di giustizia
nell'ambito di un
di un processo delle indagini di un
processo il caso manuella una storia di
droga di traffico di armi
una ci fu una scomparsa proprio
l'avvocato gianfranco manuella ci furono
omicidi suicidi un attentato con
un'autobomba questi sono gli ingredienti
un po di questa di questa storia che
ancora oggi la città di cagliari ricorda
nell'ambito delle indagini di questa
vicenda viene arrestato un giornalista
viene arrestato perché si rifiuta di
rivelare la fonte della sua informazione
dice di no al giudice
fondamentalmente tenete conto che
eravamo negli anni 70 non esisteva
per la legge italiana il segreto
professionale dei giornalisti esisteva
solo nel codice deontologico e per
questo questa storia mi ha colpito
essendo io un rappresentante di una
professione quella dell'ingegneria e il
giudice fa arrestare questo giornalista
e lui con le catene ai polsi e scortato
da due carabinieri
esce dal palazzo di giustizia e viene
tradotto così si diceva in carcere nel
carcere di buoncammino una struttura
ottocentesca tra le più dure e le più
anguste d'italia
il giorno dopo tutte le tv
le radio i giornali tutte le testate
aprirono con questa notizia nel
dibattito entra anche il presidente
della repubblica era sandro pertini
anche il presidente del consiglio nei
due giorni successivi
tv radio giornali non c'era ancora
internet non c'erano i social network
spencer o le loro voci in un silenzio
assordante in tutta la nazione
incroci anche questo è un incrocio
questo giornalista proveniva come gigi
riva anche lui da una famiglia molto
povera ottaviano pochi chilometri da qui
però lui non nasce in campania nasce in
africa a tripoli per la precisione dove
la sua famiglia si era dovuta trasferire
a causa della guerra
suo papà era prigioniero prigioniero di
guerra e vive un'infanzia difficile non
può continuare gli studi perché deve
aiutare la famiglia all'età di 16 anni
entra a lavorare nel corriere di tripoli
giornale della colonia italiana e inizia
come correttore di bozze nel
seminterrato con l'odore del piombo con
il rumore delle rotative e dopo due anni
gradino su gradino diventa il direttore
il direttore del corriere di tripoli
ho fatto una ricerca su google e ho
trovato eisenhower
ho provato questa foto come tante
insomma mentre intervistava l'ammiraglio
americano
ma torniamo a noi perché quel
giornalista è in carcere no
da quel carcere da quella cella ne esce
circa 24 ore dopo
perché si è mosso addirittura inquilini
il quirinale e palazzo chigi per aprire
quella cella
come dire un anno dopo circa un po di
più di un anno dopo la corte
costituzionale pronuncia una sentenza
storica per il nostro paese riconoscendo
l'incostituzionalità dell'operato del
giudice introduce modificandolo il
segreto professionale dei giornalisti
nel codice penale
una sentenza storica ha modificato per
sempre una professione ecco questa è una
storia che è un incrocio che ho voluto
raccontare perché la mia passione per
l'ingegneria ha fatto sì di farmela
ricordare ma per me questa storia ha un
valore anche più importante perché quel
giornalista quell'uomo era mio padre ho
finito la mia passione sono gli incroci
i miliardi di miliardi di incroci e
credo che sia importante che la voglio
lasciare un messaggio
il messaggio è questo se c'è un po di
infelicità nella nostra società non è
dovuta ai problemi ai casini che abbiamo
quotidianamente è dovuta forza forse a
una mancanza di una certa idea di noi di
noi stessi come esseri unici e
irripetibili che con la passione in ogni
nostra azione
possiamo realmente cambiare il mondo
grazie
[Musica]